皆さんはゲーム内で起きたことが現実で
起きた経験はありますか
[音楽]
[拍手]
こんにちははじめしゃちょーですゲーム内
で起きていることが現実世界にでも起き
たら美女以前ですねゲームの世界の中で
初めて社長のお家を完全再現してくれたり
したことがあったんですけどもそれすごく
なかったですかこの3億円のお家ゲームで
再現できるんだと思いまして今回ですね
アンドーンというゲームでこのはじめしゃ
ちょーの3億円のおうち
再現してもらいました
ありがとうございます対してくれたん
だろう偉い人なのかななんか公式のゲーム
の中の人のとりあえず1回ゲームの中の俺
んち見てみましょうはいというわけで早速
アンドーンやっていきたいと思います俺の
家はどこだあこれか再現
度高いはい皆さんこれが今回再現された
はじめしゃちょーの3億円のお家です
ちょっと周り見てみようかなるほど
結構なんかあの
隣に世紀末感あふれる家がありますがこれ
が安藤の世界観というのか
爆発したけども今
え俺って爆発したけど今
爆発してるってちょっと見ていきましょう
かえー
俺もこっちがいい
失礼しますあすごいすごいすごいすごい
ここが裏庭でこっちが大地間取りがもう
完璧ですね
完全にオレンジだわ失礼します
ではいはいはいはいここが玄関で
階段もありますねすごいすごいマジでね
分かる素材とか気になってるんですけども
しっかりともうすごい爆発してない
オレンジで何が起きてるんだえなんか重責
聞こえるけどもここが1階のあの編集部屋
にアップとかですね今棚とかも再現されて
ますねこの食器棚を置いて再現されてる
ゲームの中にあるもので多分再現してくれ
てるんだろうなこれ
編集部屋はもう完全に分かりますねこの棚
の感じとか照明とかもめっちゃ近いですね
ここでみんないつも編集してくれてますで
ここが2階です
失礼します
おーすごいすごいすごい
[音楽]
洋室になってるちゃんと机あるとかも
しっかり再現されてるしここのテレビも
再現されてますね
[音楽]
入られてるねこれここの棚とかももう完璧
に再現されてますね
素晴らしい
キッチンですね
キッチンも結構再現されてますね
はいはいはいはいなるほどでこっち出ると
ここもすごい再現されてるなぁ
この柵をね
ここ
庭ですね今の周りの花壇とか
ヤシの木とかもちゃんと再現されてますね
この外の家がマジで気になるな行ってみ
たい
え人いるなんかエロい女おるぞエロい女
いっぱいおるよ女の子
達ってサウナゾーン行ってみようかな
[音楽]
すごい
めっちゃ女性俺サメだゾーン
さぁえっと
[音楽]
これは
きっと作っていただけたんですよこれはね
サウナですちゃんと暖炉燃えてるし囲んで
あるからもうサウナですこれどう見ても
この女性たちは今置いといてちょっと他の
部屋も見ていきましょうはいはいはいはい
[音楽]
トイレ
あーここもね
見渡せる場所になってるからあってますね
この感じでここが管理人室ですね
若干ロッカーみたいになってますけどで
こっちが
失礼しますあこっち今畑の撮影部屋ですね
あーなんかポップな感じがすごい
似ているようで似てないカラフルな感情が
かなり再現されてますねポップな感じで
かなり忠実に再現されてると思いますえ女
の人来たあ待ってーこんにちは
[音楽]
ないぞあー
逃げたあー危ないました4回行きます
失礼します
あーまた女の人いる嬉しいここが4階の
キッチンですね
柱とかもちゃんと再現されてるし
キッチンの形もあってるいやこれ結構再現
ってすごいぞ次は僕がさっき撮影してた
撮影部屋見に行きましょう俺のメイン
ルームです
ここださっき撮ってたところソファーも
青いソファー作ってくれたりテーブル置い
てあったり編集机とモニターをちゃんと
置いてあるしここの棚もあります
素晴らしい
[音楽]
ねシャワールームだこれオレンジないです
で洗面所からの浴槽を見に行きましょう僕
でジャグジー
付きのお風呂
でかーこれ入れるんかな
[音楽]
おー入れるいやオレンジのジャグジーより
でかいぞ
羨ましいはいということで安藤という
ゲームの世界で初めてのうち再現して
もらいましたやっぱりゲームってさその
ものとかアイテムが限られてるからさ家具
とかも素材とか本当にある素材でこの
クオリティかなり頑張っていただいたのか
なと思って見てます外装とかも完璧だから
ねいや素晴らしい出来ですありがとう
ございます
ですが今回の企画これだけではありません
さっきさ女の子たくさんいたじゃないです
か今回の企画今からこの行灯というゲーム
後輩たちにちょっと遊ばせます後輩が遊ん
でる時にさっきゲーム内にいた大量の
女の子たちを
ぶっこみます例えば後輩ですねすごい
めっちゃ似てる
で遊んでる時に
なんか奥から女の人かあれなんかこっち来
ましたけどはじめさんあれ女の人います
けど
めっちゃ可愛いあれあれあれあれあれあれ
初めて女の子たくさん来ましたけども
はじめさんこれ
女の人たくさん来ましたけどはいっていう
感じで後輩がゲームしてる時に女の人たち
をたくさんゲーム内に出現させてそれを
現実世界でも起こします
[音楽]
後輩大歓喜ゲームの中であったことが実際
に現実に起きるとどういう反応するのか
ちょっと見ていきたいと思います
今日はちょっと一緒にやりたいゲームが
あるはいやろう
というゲームなんだけどちょっと開けてみ
て開けてみますはい
あれ
こっち側とこっち側こっちですか
これ
見てみよううわ
はいわかりましたサーベがこの家で一番
よくいる場所どこうわ俺は最近は4回とか
ですかね4階の4階のこのまさに部屋とか
寝室とか寝室行ってみましょう
扉ですよ
行っちゃってくださいもういきますねいつ
もいつもここを
クイッといって右に曲がってうわーこの
柱とかもガチだ寝室ここですね行きます
[音楽]
すごいいつもどこでどっち側寝てるいや俺
いつも左側に似てますか
寝ちゃったねこれ
ゲームでも一緒に寝れるようになったって
ことですかまさか
女の子エロ
エロえー
なんか女の子
めっちゃ
隣にいるんですけどハーレムゲームって
ことですかこれ違ううわうわうわうわうわ
うわうわうわうわうわうわうわうわうわえ
どういう状況どっから湧き出てくるのこれ
[音楽]
ちょっと女がめっちゃいます
殴られてるこういうサービスさんゲームの
世界だったら俺ん家でこうやって女の子と
か呼んだりできるの
ハーレムとかね
すごいでしょすごいですこれ感動した感動
しましたこれこれ以上はできないですか
[音楽]
失礼します
おやすみなさい
[音楽]
ます
か寒くないですか
さっきの人やば
[音楽]
多くないですか
ちょっと待って
やばい
[音楽]
えーっと
お願いします
[音楽]
いやいやいやいやいやいやダメでしょこれ
痛い痛い
やば
俺もやっていいですか
ありがとうございます
いやもう
緊張したっすね結構忠実だった一人殴って
たじゃん本当にあれありなんですか
[音楽]
裸で入れちゃうんです
か
これサウナです
すごいね特殊な近未来的なんですよ
頑張って再現してもらえたらこれこれ
座っちゃうよ
[音楽]
すごいね
女の子来たあれえ
すごいすごいすごい
このゲームめちゃめちゃ熱いやん
座るとこ間違えたなこれ
[音楽]
あいつ座りたい
ぐらいにね
ローリングしてる
のこれ
[音楽]
おいおいおいおいおいおいおいおいおい
おい
[音楽]
手洗うところじゃないよ
見ろおいおいおいおいおいおいおい天国か
ここはどうですかこれ最高でしょこれ
このゲーム使うとですね家に女も呼べちゃ
うっていうマジかマッチングアプリみたい
なゲームですねこれ違います違いますね
この後さ一応あれ取っときたいんよね
[音楽]
失礼しますね
大丈夫かいや
完璧です
完璧
いいサウナだな
ぁ
マジでやばすぎ
る
[音楽]
これ最高最高
絶景です
[音楽]
皆さんお疲れ様でした
お疲れ様です
[音楽]
ゲーム内で起きたことが現実にも起きる
ドッキリでした
どうでした最高ですね最高だけど逆にどう
すればいいかわかんなくなっちゃうね
ゲームは夢の世界です
けどいざいるとちょっと
緊張してますね
[音楽]
持ってきました歩いてみてくださいはい
はいはいはい
リアルですね
3億円の家や
作ってもらいました
すごいでしょうわこれガラスの感じといい
このねコンクリート調というスマホでこの
綺麗さすごくないマジですごいちょっと
入ってみてください
お邪魔しますはいお邪魔します4
階のこれ撮影部屋です
[音楽]
喉がカラカラです
ここ開けると4回ですね
[音楽]
はい再現されてますよ
座ってみてくださいね
席に着く
できてるんですよ
座りながらもちょっと見てもらってこれ
作れるのか
スマホっていうのがあったね
[音楽]
[笑い]
ありがとういいゲームすごいいいゲーム
[音楽]
私にいます
すごいいっぱいいるね
[音楽]
うまい言ってたダメだって結婚してる人に
やっちゃう
ゲームの中で起きたことが現実でも起きて
しまうドッキリでした
[笑い]
[音楽]
これ3億円の
豪邸の4階のお風呂場でちょっとゲーム
やってもらおうと思いまして
[音楽]
ちょっとは前に進んでみてもらっていい
です
[音楽]
植物もあってそううわすごいちょっと
どうせだったらさ今いるここまで行って
みようぜお風呂場
どんだけここと似てるかもしれない見て
もらおうと思って4回ですよねはい今こう
3回はいはいはいはい
[音楽]
で4階ですか
いやすごいすごい
[音楽]
失礼します
すごい
なぁ
なんか人がめっちゃ
怖い怖い
[拍手]
[音楽]
すごいね
[拍手]
マジ最悪
[音楽]
もうちょっと一緒に入りたかった
ありがとうございましたありがとうござい
ましたはいというわけで今回ですねアン
ドーンをプレイさせていただいたんです
けれども今回みたいにゲーム内で自分だけ
の空間を作ったりハウジングできたりなん
と自分だけのオリジナルキャラの作れます
でアンノーンなんですけども何がすごいっ
て
めちゃくちゃ
リアルなサバイバル生活をするゲームに
なってます食料確保
終了
魚釣り選択お風呂トレーニングもうほんと
人間の生活みたいにプレイするのが行燈
ですしかもアンドン声優がめちゃくちゃ
豪華でしてなんと主人公の声があの
梶裕貴さんが担当してますすごい
[拍手]
そして最後になるんですがなんと今総額
100万円分の
豪華商品のありえないあんどーんという
大型キャンペーンがやっておりますそして
あの
ウィルスミスさんが登場するっていう
キャンペーンがやっているみたいなので
詳しくは概要欄のTwitterリンクを
見てみてください
ウィルスミスさんに100万円分の
キャンペーン
めっちゃ安藤盛り上がっていますぜひ遊ん
でみてくださいせーのジャーン
ありがとうございました
[音楽]